Mō tātou, a, mō ka uri a muri ake nei
Here we are on a nice, sunny, winter's day
on the south bank of the Kaiapoi River.
The object of our endeavours was to link the
library and the main street
with the river bank.
Lot's of boardwalk, seating, areas for children
to fish, and the whole thing is just on finished
and the grass seed is down and when that grows,
the project will be finished.
And of course the whole thing compliments
our terraces across the river in front of
Jedd's proposed new scheme.
So this month is all about the waterfront
development here in Kaiapoi.
As Al has already mentioned, a lot's already been completed
and it's starting to look really good.
Next up for construction, is the boardwalk
and seating area
on the north bank of the river.
Kevin Dwyer is the landscape architect who
has been working on the designs.
So Kevin, can you tell us what's happening
in this part of the river?
Just behind us here is going to be a private
development, hospitality and retail and fronting
that is going to be a boardwalk that links
the town centre across the front of the new
development and down towards the riverbank
walkway.
Fronting the timber boardwalk is a series
of concrete terraces with built-in timber
seating that leads down to the top of the
riverbank, and that will be a really nice
space for people to come down, have their
lunch, have a cup of coffee
and interact more with the river.
And what are some of the challenges that you
are facing with this project?
We've had to integrate our design with the design
of the private development and also
the rebuild of the stopbank wall by ECAN.
And it's just the timing of that, and getting
the design, working together
It's probably been the biggest challenge so far.
Construction should begin later this year,
and is expected to be completed in 2018.
Work also continues with local developer,
Jedd Pearce on a proposed riverfront
shopping and dining complex.
Preliminary designs are complete, with a microbrewery
and bar proposed as an anchor tenant.
The design of the building will allow visitors
to experience the brewing process,
while enjoying food and views of the river.
As part of the riverfront enhancement, we’ve
placed a new information panel opposite the library.
This is one more way that the local community
can keep up to date with the latest developments.
Currently we seeking feedback on two roading
options for access to the new sport and recreation
reserve in the Kaiapoi East Regeneration Area.
In Option 1, Cass Street remains open to access
the reserve, rural area and private property.
Option 2, is an alternative where Cass Street
is closed to vehicles at the entrance to the
reserve and Jollie Street is reinstated.
We’d love to hear what option you prefer.
Next update, we’ll be meeting some Kaiapoi
students who have big ideas for the Regeneration
and looking at the ways local youth can have
their say.